-This sounds
like a "Curb" story,
but it happened
in your real life.
-What´s that?
-You, in the time
since the last "Curb" season,
you spent a night in jail.
You got arrested.
-Oh, my God!
What are you
bringing that up for?
I don´t need that crap.
[ Laughter ]
What are you --
Well, you know, all right.
[ Laughter ]
On -- In a --
Oh, what are you doing to me?!
[ Laughter ]
I spent a night in jail.
Yes, Seth.
-Okay.
-Bring up a sad memory.
Do you ever think a guy like me
is gonna end up in jail?
But here´s the thing
I´m gonna say to you.
-Yeah.
-Okay, I ended up in jail.
It was a minor altercation.
-Yeah.
-And --
It really was.
And I got put in jail because
the woman had an expensive car.
-Uh-huh.
-And when I went
in her window and --
She was making fun of me
for being fat.
-Okay.
-That´s all I´m saying.
Weird, right?!
-Yeah.
-And -- I don´t have enough time
to tell the story!
This is what you do to me.
You ask me a question,
the entire segment --
Do I have two segments tonight?
-No, you don´t
have two segments.
-I know,
there´s a novelist coming,
who maybe she´ll write a book
on my thing.
[ Laughter ]
Here´s all
I´m gonna say to you, though.
-Okay.
-The reality is, I hit
on someone´s window and said,
"Why did you do that?"
you know?
-Yeah.
-It was a dumb Larry David move,
because, like,
she was yelling at me,
and then I said,
"Well, why´d you make fun of me
for being fat?"
It was the wrong time.
-Yeah.
-Anyhow, TMZ had me
with a wrench, busting windows,
and then leaping on her car
and saying,
"You better call the coppers."
[ Laughter ]
-But that didn´t happen.
-No!
-It was just this.
You gave it a tap.
-Not a tap.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I´m a strong man!
I didn´t realize that strong.
And you know, like, a window,
it shattered -- not on her,
but, like, right there.
And it was like, "Oh."
When it happened,
I was like, "Whoa!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"No, that was not
what I wanted!"
-Did you know
when it shattered --
How fast did you process,
"I might go to jail"?
-Not at all.
-Okay.
You still thought you were fine.
-As a matter of fact,
I went into the store
to get my prescription.
By the way,
bought some Twizzlers.
I´m diabetic.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And came out,
and she was still there,
screaming for the police,
even though I gave her
my information.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And then the cops arrested me
because they said --
I said,
"Why are you arresting me?"
They said,
"Well, if she was driving
a Toyota Corolla,
you would be fine.
But it´s a Mercedes S500,
so we´re arresting you
for felony vandalism."
-Ah, ´cause it was
a certain cost.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I will say, you were --
That is a stone-cold
criminal move
to commit felony vandalism
and then go buy Twizzlers.
[ Laughter ]
The cops show up, and you´re
just eating Twizzlers.
-By the way,
which only led to more anxiety,
and I was more scared
´cause I had a sugar high,
and I was like, "You´re putting
cookies in the room.
I´m bound
to get arrested tonight."
-Now, I have to ask,
when you got to jail
were the arresting officers --
-Okay.
All right, here´s the key thing.
All right, I see where
you´re going down the path.
-I´m not going anywhere!
-You heard the story!
So I get to the jail,
and all I´ve --
I´m not gonna do like
what´s-her-name did,
"Do you know who I am?"
you know, type thing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Or anyone does that.
-No.
-That´s not me.
I wish I had done it now,
though.
-Uh-huh.
-All right, so anyhow,
I´m at the jail,
and all I´m thinking is,
"Please, one of the
police officers know me.
Know me!"
"Oh, we got a --
Jeff, what are you doing here?
We´ll put you over here.
Maybe we´ll get you a cookie.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-None of the cops knew me.
Every criminal knew me!
[ Laughter and applause ]
If --
[ Laughs ]
If you were handcuffed,
you were thrilled.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God!
What are you here for?"
"I just got a little
felony vandalism.
What are you here for?"
"Oh, just robbed a family.
I love your work, you know,
when I´m not robbing people."
-Did you -- Not to obsess
over the Twizzlers,
but was that a situation where,
when you get there,
they take it and put it in
one of those plastic things?
-No, no, no.
It was a big jumbo package.
-Uh-huh.
-It was gone by the time
they took me away.
-Oh, wow.
-As I was standing there,
I was just downing Twizzlers.
There was --
There was no bag to put it away.
My son´s earache medicine,
yes, they held that for me.
-Okay, well, that´s very nice.
-Yes.
-Oh, my goodness.
So you were going to get
earache medicine for your son.
-Yes, he had an ear infection.
But they dropped the charges
on the Monday.
And I want to thank, by the way,
Kanye West and Kim Kardashian,
because the next day,
after I was released,
I was no longer on TMZ
because North West was born.
-Oh, perfect.
-So some people
may have problems with them.
I have none!
[ Laughter ]
I am thrilled with them.
I love them.
And you know what else?
Can I have one second, please?
-Of course.
-This is, like, serious.
So I had --
They dropped the charges.
But the city
wanted to meet with me.
So my lawyer said,
"Go take some anger mana--"
You know, meet with some --
for anger management.
-Yeah.
-I´m like,
"I don´t have anger management."
I found out
I don´t have anger management.
What I found out,
and this is not a joke,
is that I have an ego problem,
´cause I had
righteous indignation.
Like, "Why would she
make fun of for being fat?"
It was over a parking space.
So stupid.
And I learned
that ego does nothing for you.
It´s about being humble
and being confident
in who you are and what you do.
But I learned
a great lesson about ego
and how it does me no good.
And so I would --
I was saying,
"I wish I had said something."
I´m glad I didn´t say,
"Do you know who I am?"
that I experienced this,
because, man, that ego thing,
it´s beautiful.
-Oh, that´s fantastic.
-Yeah.
-So it was, in the end,
a positive.
-Very positive.
-That´s great.
-And I would go through it again
to learn that.
-That´s fantastic.
-Yeah.
-And thank you so much
for telling that story.
I really appreciate it.
-Oh, sure.
-Sorry for putting you
on the spot.